what follows is a broad overview of the
study of human language please explore
the specific lesson playlists on this
channel or visit native Lankin slash
linguistics to learn more what is
linguistics well we can use it as a term
for nothing less than the study of
language so how do we define human
language and how can we study it that
leads to a number of questions both
ancient and modern from the time of
paninis sanskrit grammar to modern
computational linguistics what are the
building blocks of human language and
how can we model explain or account for
natural language answering those
questions leads directly to theory
theoretical linguistics explores sound
structure of individual languages the
way speakers put sentences together how
speaker's build words the role of
meaning and language word choice and
vocabulary and meaning and use in
context but do we study speech or
writing in our effort to explain human
language modern disciplines focus on
spoken language as it's more spontaneous
and universal but we can also learn and
theorize about writing systems
what if we focused on describing human
language instead of modeling its
structure more abstractly or
theoretically from here we can head to
comparing languages and we can show how
they change over time and how one
language relates to another genetically
linguists can describe the real-life
spoken languages indigenous to peoples
across the globe from a wide range of
cultures they can describe the social
variation of a language within a single
culture and even how humans make speech
sounds and for marks on the page to
write what if we ask instead how is
language relevant to everyday life
languages learned and taught processed
by computers language relies on human
biology languages intertwined with the
role of the brain and its functions and
it has many other applications let's
take one last angle what tools do we use
to study human language
these include field notes grammar books
parse trees dusty manuscripts
statistical models and datasets
derivations spectrograms
and just plain mental analysis and
question to mention but a few linguistic
tools drawn in random order there are
many questions to ask about natural
language and many ways to talk and think
about languages I hope this top-level
slice gives you a taste of the variety
of approaches available to you